good morning John it's Thursday so as I
mentioned very briefly in my last video
I finished a draft of my but what does
that mean it means that there's a
hundred and forty something thousand
words in a document and there's a
beginning in the middle and an end
are they the words that are gonna be in
the final book some of them almost
definitely I went to see Tommy orange
who wrote they're there last night he
gave like a QA at the University of
Montana and at one point in the talk he
referred to himself as a kind of duality
there are times when he's a writer and
there's a times when he's a revisionist
and that's a completely different job
one last thing that he said that really
resonated with me about writing and I
can't remember exactly how he said it
but basically you have to be a reader of
your own work and you have to experience
it that way you have to just like with
music or with any other art you have to
try and experience the thing you made
and in that process enjoy your own work
and I have started revising and I really
enjoy this story it's a mess but I think
it's gonna be good and not answer some
questions about writing and about the
book specifically that I got on Twitter
any question other than when is it out
is irrelevant I don't know it's much
sooner now that I finished a draft
though lots of things still need to get
done I have a lot of people read my work
before I publish it though I don't know
what I do know is that it's happening at
least Britney wants to know am I going
to cry
well I cried in the Chipotle as I was
finishing writing the book what is the
title of your new book are you allowed
to say yet no I'm not soon as I know for
sure I'll tell you because I don't want
to do is be like what about this and
you'd be like I hate it I want to be
like this is it and then you won't tell
me if you hate it because that's mean
how many pages first book is three
hundred and thirtysomething pages long
this book will probably be over four
hundred I hope it's okay it's a more
involved story a lot more happen to get
a lot more points of view if you know
what I mean Jennifer wants to know if
it's gonna be a trilogy it's not this is
it life geek wants to know when is your
deadline my deadline was October 2nd and
I missed it and then I imposed on myself
an artificial deadline of pizza mess
because pizza miss that asks are there
any McIlroy references in the book I
mean probably well maybe I'll go back
and add one just for you I will see
there's a lot of Keanu referee
is despot Seto in this book seat now
this is the problem now I want to add
despedido into the book kata asks have
any current events and development in
the social media internet discourse
world changed the structure or focus of
the sequel or given you a different
perspective compared to an absolute
remarkable a question yeah totally
the first book was very much about what
the internet is like right now or was
like a couple years ago and this book is
attempting to think about what the
social internet might be like pretty far
in the future book doesn't take place
far in the future but the world is much
more different in this book than it is
from our world in the first book if that
makes any sense at all hopefully it will
make sense when you read the book what
color will the cover be I think it's
gonna be orange any new characters
joining the man gang yes yes what's been
the hardest thing with this book as I
have alluded to the book is written from
multiple perspectives so like a a bunch
of the previous characters are now
point-of-view characters they are
writing the book themselves this it
turns out as hard a voice is difficult
and and to have like to store like four
or five different people's voices in my
head I have had to learn a lot which is
great I mean that's part of why I like
making any art is thinking really hard
about it
learning how it works watching other
people do it really well knowing you're
never gonna do it that well but then
trying anyway man monster asks how do
you feel and I feel really good like
there were times that I didn't it was
stressful a lot it was a lot of nights
put in but I feel like I got better at
stuff while I worked on it and so far
I'm enjoying reading it as a revisionist
and I hope that it will hit your
bookshelves sometime within the next 12
months we'll just say that John I'll see
you on Friday